he hablado mucho de la importancia de la
hemoglobina en los glóbulos rojos y
pensé en dedicarle todo un vídeo a la
hemoglobina la principal razón es porque
es importante pero también explica mucho
de cómo la hemoglobina o los glóbulos
rojos depende de cuál nivel quieras
operar sabe
y tengo que escribir sabe entre comillas
no es un ser sensible como sabe cuando
recoger el oxígeno y cuando liberar el
oxígeno esto de aquí es de hecho una
imagen de una proteína de hemoglobina
esta es la
como propina
está conformada por cuatro cadenas de
aminoácidos esta es una de ellas estas
son las otras tres y no entraremos en
detalles en eso pero estas se ven como
pequeños listones rizados si las
imaginas son un montón de moléculas y
aminoácidos y luego se enrollan de esta
manera esto describe su forma en cierto
nivel y en cada uno de esos grupos o en
cada una de esas cadenas tienes un grupo
hemo tienes un grupo hemo aquí en verde
grupo
de ahí es donde sale el hemo en
hemoglobina tienes cuatro grupos hemo y
globina está esencialmente describiendo
el resto las estructuras de proteína las
cuatro cadenas peptídicas ahora este
grupo hemo es bastante interesante es de
hecho una estructura por phil y nica y
si viste el vídeo de la clorofila
recordarás las estructuras por fin y
nicas pero justo en el centro de ella en
la clorofila tenemos unión de magnesio
pero en el centro de la hemoglobina
tenemos un guión
t
y aquí es donde el oxígeno se enlaza en
este módulo bina tienes cuatro sitios
principales de unión para el oxígeno
aquí hay uno tal vez hay un poco atrás
ahí y ahí sabes que el oxígeno se
enlazará con mucha facilidad aquí la
hemoglobina tiene varias propiedades y
una la hace muy buena enlazando oxígeno
y también es muy buena a liberar oxígeno
cuando tiene que hacerlo exhibe algo
conocido como unión
era activa
y este es solo el principio de que una
vez que se enlaza a una molécula de
oxígeno digamos que una molécula de
oxígeno se une ay cambia la forma de tal
manera que sea más probable que en los
otros lugares enlace oxígeno
en la cee
hace otros enlaces más probables hace
otros
enlaces
más
inglés
ahora dirás de acuerdo está bien eso lo
hace un muy buen aceptador de oxígeno
cuando viaja a través de los capilares
pulmonares y el oxígeno se está
difundiendo de los alveolos es muy buena
recogiendo el oxígeno pero como sabe
cuando liberar el oxígeno esta es una
pregunta interesante
cuándo
liberar
o sí
no tiene ojos son algún tipo de sistema
gps que diga oye sabes que este sujeto
está corriendo ahora por lo que está
generando mucho dióxido de carbono ahora
en estos capilares necesita mucho
oxígeno en estos capilares que rodean su
cuádriceps necesita entregar oxígeno no
sabe que está en el cuádriceps
como sabe la hemoglobina que tiene que
liberar el oxígeno ahí y ese es un
subproducto de lo que llamamos
inhibición a los tehrik a la cual es una
palabra bastante compleja pero los
conceptos son bastante claros inhibición
a los estéticas
aunque este término se usa con
frecuencia en el contexto de las enzimas
en general cuando decimos que algo es a
los tehrik o nos referimos a la idea de
que hay cosas que se adhieren a otras
partes a los significa a otro así que te
estás enlazando a otras partes de la
proteína o la enzima y las enzimas son
solo proteínas y afecta la habilidad de
las proteínas o de la enzima para hacer
lo que normalmente hace la hemoglobina
desinhibida a los teóricamente por el
dióxido de carbono y por protones el
dióxido de carbono se puede enlazar a
otras partes de la hemoglobina no sé los
lugares exactos y de la misma manera
pueden hacerlo los protones recuerda que
así ves significa que hay una
concentración alta de protones así que
si estás en un ambiente ácido los
protones se pueden unir quizá haga los
protones en este color rosa los protones
los cuales son solo hidrógenos sin
electrones los protones pueden enlazarse
ciertas partes de nuestra proteína y
esto hace que les sea más difícil
retener oxígeno cuando estás en la
presencia de mucho dióxido de carbono o
un ambiente ácido esta hemoglobina
dejará ir sub oxígeno y sucede que ese
es un muy buen momento para dejar ir el
oxígeno volvamos a este sujeto corriendo
él está corriendo hay mucha actividad en
estas células de aquí en sus cuádriceps
están liberando mucho dióxido de carbono
en los capilares en este punto está el
cambio de arterias a venas y necesitan
mucho oxígeno por lo que es un excelente
momento para que la hemoglobina libere
el oxígeno es muy bueno que la
hemoglobina esté ni vida a los
teóricamente por dióxido de carbono el
dióxido de carbono se enlaza a distintas
partes de ella empieza a dejar ir su
oxígeno exactamente en la parte del
cuerpo que se necesite y ahora dirás qué
sucederá con este ambiente ácido como
interviene esto
resulta que la mayor parte del dióxido
de carbono está de hecho es asociado si
va al plasma pero es transformado en
ácido carbónico escribiré una pequeña
fórmula aquí si tienes algo de co2 y lo
mezclas con el agua la mayor parte de
nuestra sangre
el plasma es agua si tomas algo de
dióxido de carbono y lo mezclas con agua
y lo tienes en la presencia de una
enzima y esta enzima existe en los
glóbulos rojos y es llamada anhídrido
carbónico
y
todos
col
ocurrirá una reacción y esencialmente
acabarás con ácido carbónico obtendremos
h-2c o tres todo está balanceado tenemos
tres oxígenos dos hidrógenos y un
carbono y el llamado ácido carbónico
porque se de protones de hidrógeno muy
fácilmente los ácidos se disocian en su
base conjugada y en sus protones de
hidrógeno de una manera muy sencilla el
ácido carbónico
se disocia muy fácil es un ácido pero lo
escribiré en una ecuación química si
algo de esta anotación te confunde mucho
o si quieres saber más detalles al
respecto mira algunos de los vídeos de
química de disociación de ácidos
reacciones de equilibrio u otros temas
relacionados pero esencialmente puede
ser uno de estos hidrógenos pero solo el
protón y se queda con el electrón del
hidrógeno así que nos queda un protón de
hidrógeno más este se dio uno de sus
hidrógenos tenemos un hidrógeno este es
de hecho un guión bicarbonato este de
aquí es bicarbonato solo cedió el protón
pero se quedó con el electrón por lo que
tiene es un signo negativo si sumamos
todas las cargas vemos que esto es
neutro si estoy en un capilar de la
pierna déjame ver si puedo dibujar esto
digamos que estoy en el capilar de mi
pierna
este es el capilar de mi pierna hice una
ampliación de una parte del capital
siempre se está ramificando
y por aquí tengo un grupo grande de
células musculares justo aquí que están
generando mucho dióxido de carbono
generan mucho dióxido de carbono y
necesitan oxígeno bueno qué pasará
tengo mis glóbulos rojos fluyendo de
hecho es interesante el diámetro de los
glóbulos rojos es 25% más grande que el
capilar más pequeño así que
esencialmente son exprimidos mientras
van a lo largo de pequeños capilares lo
que mucha gente piensa que les ayuda a
liberar su contenido
libera algo del oxígeno que está dentro
de ellos tienes un glóbulo rojo aquí que
está siendo exprimido a través de este
capilar de aquí tiene bastantes
hemoglobinas y cuando digo bastantes
debería decirte ahora que cada glóbulo
rojo tiene 270 millones de proteínas de
hemoglobina 270 millones y si sumas el
total de hemoglobina en el cuerpo humano
es un número bastante grande porque
tienes de 20 a 30
y yo mes
r p
qué son las siglas en inglés para
glóbulos rojos y cada uno de esos 20 a
30 billones de glóbulos rojos tiene 270
millones de proteínas de
lo vi
en ellos así que tenemos muchas
hemoglobinas de hecho los glóbulos rojos
componen el 25 por ciento de todas las
células que hay en nuestro cuerpo
tenemos alrededor de 100 billones o un
poco más aproximadamente nunca me he
sentado a contarlas tenemos 270 millones
de partículas sus proteínas de
hemoglobina en cada glóbulo rojo eso
explica por qué los glóbulos rojos
tienen que deshacerse de sus núcleos
para hacer espacio para todas esas
hemoglobina se está encargando oxígeno
aquí tenemos una ar
viene del corazón los glóbulos rojos van
en esa dirección y luego va a liberar su
oxígeno y se convertirá en una de la
ahora lo que pasará es que tienes este
dióxido de carbono
tienes una concentración alta de dióxido
de carbono en la célula muscular
entonces llegará un momento en el que
solo por un gradiente de difusión acaba
en el plasma de la sangre
de esta manera y parte de él puede
atravesar la membrana hacia el interior
del glóbulo rojo en el glóbulo rojo
tienes este anhídrido carbónico el cual
hace que el dióxido de carbono se les
asocie en o esencialmente se vuelva
ácido carbónico el cual después puede
liberar protones déjame dibujar a los
protones aquí acabamos de aprender que
esos protones pueden inhibir a los
teóricamente la recepción de oxígeno por
la hemoglobina así que esos protones
empiezan a enlazarse en diferentes
partes e incluso el dióxido de carbono
que no ha reaccionado puede también
inhibir a los teóricamente a la
hemoglobina así que también se une a
otras partes y eso cambia la forma de la
proteína de hemoglobina lo suficiente
para que no pueda enlazarse también al
oxígeno y empiece a liberarse y como
dijimos antes tenemos unión cooperativa
entre más oxígeno tengas es mucho más
sencillo aceptar
y pasa lo opuesto cuando empiezas a
liberar oxígeno se vuelve más difícil
retener los demás y después del primero
todos los oxígenos se liberan por lo
menos en mi mente es un mecanismo
brillante porque el oxígeno se libera
justo en el sitio donde tiene que ser
liberado no solo dice he dejado una
arteria y ahora estoy en una vena quizás
fui a través de algunos capilares aquí y
volveré a una vena déjame liberar mi
oxígeno porque de esta manera sólo
liberará el oxígeno a lo largo del
cuerpo queramos o no este sistema al ser
inhibido a los teóricamente por dióxido
de carbono y en un ambiente ácido
permite liberar oxígeno donde es más
necesario donde hay la mayor cantidad de
dióxido de carbono donde la respiración
está ocurriendo de una manera más
vigorosa es un sistema fascinante y solo
para entender mejor aquí abajo
tengo esta pequeña gráfica que muestra
la toma de oxígeno por la hemoglobina
qué tan saturada puede ser y quizá
puedas ver esto en tu clase de biología
es algo bueno que entender
aquí abajo en el eje x tenemos o en el
eje horizontal tenemos la presión
parcial del oxígeno y si viste en los
vídeos de química de la presión parcial
sabes qué presión parcial solo significa
que tan frecuente chocan las moléculas
en este caso de oxígeno unas contra
otras la presión es generada por gases o
moléculas que chocan contra ti no tiene
que ser gas pueden ser solo moléculas
que chocan contra ti y luego la presión
parcial de oxígeno es la cantidad de eso
que es generado por las moléculas de
oxígeno que chocan contra ti puedes
imaginar mientras vas a la derecha que
cada vez hay más oxígeno así que las
moléculas de oxígeno chocarán contra ti
con cada vez más frecuencia esto está
diciendo esencialmente cuánto oxígeno
hay alrededor mientras vas hacia la
derecha del eje y luego el eje vertical
te dice que tan saturadas están tus
moléculas de hemoglobina este 100%
significa que todos tus grupos hemo o
todas las moléculas
más de hemoglobina se han unido al
oxígeno pero significa ninguna cuando
tienes un ambiente con muy poco oxígeno
y esto muestra la unión cooperativa
digamos que estamos viendo un ambiente
con oxígeno muy bajo una vez que un poco
de oxígeno se enlaza entonces hace mucho
más probable que cada vez más oxígeno se
enlace es por eso que está pendiente
está creciendo no quiero hablar de
álgebra y de cálculo aquí pero puedes
ver que empieza un poco plana y luego la
pendiente crece cuando se enlaza algo de
oxígeno es más probable que más enlace y
en cierto punto será difícil para las
moléculas de oxígeno chocar justo de la
manera correcta contra las moléculas de
hemoglobina adecuadas pero puedes ver
que parece acelerarse más o menos por
aquí ahora si tenemos un ambiente ácido
que tiene mucho dióxido de carbono por
lo que la hemoglobina es significa los
teóricamente no será tan bueno como esto
un ambiente ácido esta curva para
cualquier nivel de presión parcial de
oxígeno o cualquier cantidad de oxígeno
tendremos menos hemoglobina enlazada
déjame hacer eso en colores diferentes
luego la curva se verá así
la curva de saturación se verá así este
es un ambiente aquí tenemos un
diente
ácido
tal vez hay algo de dióxido de carbono
aquí alrededor y la hemoglobina
está haciendo mi vida
a los teóricamente es más probable que
se libere oxígeno en este punto no sé
qué tan emocionante hayas encontrado eso
pero a mí me parece brillante porque es
la manera más sencilla para que la
hemoglobina libere el oxígeno donde se
necesita sin necesidad de gps ni robots
para decir oh estoy ahora en el
cuádriceps y el sujeto está corriendo
déjame liberarme oxígeno aquí lo hace
naturalmente porque es un ambiente ácido
con más dióxido de carbono se inhibe y
luego el oxígeno es liberado y listo
para usarse para la respiración